it's almost time to go but before we do
we love to leave you with a little
something to take to go and we call it
the doggy bag
there he goes and today it's a handy
dandy little tip care of tick tock ross
you know when you want to wrap a towel
around your waist like after a shower at
the pool well actually i know you rock
it like a serious amazing caftan one
that you made personally yeah it's true
um but then it keeps like falling off
and the towel yeah i can never figure
out how they do that people do it so it
stays on tight okay well this comes from
brayden singley a choreographer and
dancer and apparently towel genius take
a look
what if you tuck the excess
underneath
you're invincible murder in the shower
run away
okay so wait what did he do there
okay you
does anyone else do this
i mean i i i feel like i do it like this
and it just falls off well that's why
because you got to wrap it here and then
you fold it over once and sometimes i'll
even fold it over twice because then
you're just like i don't know i i feel
like i'm in the blue lagoon i've got my
loin cloth but why is mine so short
though drew what this is not look look
at liv
that's not a cute look someone whistled
do not
pity
me do not
look this is not a cute look i don't
know rossie i think you look pretty cute
no i would tell you you would
of course i would i believe you well you
don't look cute take it off oh okay
thank you
well i'm telling you it does do the
trick and especially if you're like
swimming out i do that because i have a
bathing suit on the top i don't swim
topless
unless i'm alone it's really staying
though can i look i'm jumping it's not
going anywhere
okay i'm gonna work on mine it wasn't
cute you keep talking all right well
thank you so much to our guests here in
the audience today and everybody wants
to get home
with us we hope you have a fantastic day
and we hope you take all of this with
you
[Music]